okay welcome to this video playing unsat
sue playing trying to be quick here my
neighbor transpose no we don't to some
kind of symmetrical English okay yep 697
Castle that's a pretty good setup for
black sound sound and reliable see going
for a 4 here I don't know ok let's try
to force III yep okay do I go p6
probably I was difficult to imagine how
I develop their okay if I'm taking okay
let's not be too quick here hmm i wonder
if I have chances to win this Bishop
down doesn't have many squares yes
counter-attacking most likely form
that's probably the problem that's
probably the problem okay I'm going to
go here instead of losing any more time
it was interesting taking 45 but yet if
I looked fishy considering my very weak
long diagonal so I'm sticking with the
keep it simple attitude
wow that move would have been very low
on my list of expected moves interesting
I don't really get it to be honest
what's the idea you for at some point
somebody's annoying this Queen so let
it's a Tekkit now as bishop is say the
secure at least but don't feel it cannot
go afore I cannot play G form but with
the moves look look weird again she
taking at five wow wow so he doesn't
care about his light squares maybe it's
not so important but still okay let's go
for this
hmm
okay yeah if I go Bishop to your form
Queenie to my bishop is basically
trapped that's definitely true
maybe this one has an interesting queen
d 5 is I think quite bad due to Queen a
2 okay still plays it and quickly yeah
maybe i'm wrong but i thought that this
is just good for me isn't this good when
he's in a pin be to Hanks threatening
bishop you form hmm
hmm
okay so i have Bishop c4 now mmm I don't
know something better somewhere I wish
if she was just blundering nonsense what
a nonsensical move okay um Angie has 93
sometimes ok not easy a seven also hang
so
and maybe here this night is very strong
very obstructing peace
maybe he's not taking it even nope he
does take it okay grabbing them I
thought my beep on would be strong and
Queen d2 comes with the tempo okay do
that and troop c 1 c 1 here I just got
Bishop t6 ok that's a draw though with
taking a queen d1 some more here chapter
2 can then the beep on ok let's push the
beep on
time warning
hmm can go to to check here cannot cover
this bloody pawn down the NT take me to
one believer again okay I cannot go gave
hate just brilliant check yeah
afterwards again the comp will show me
how I could have won this game yeah it's
a good story yeah yeah and now it moves
the bishop and picks picks up this pawn
it's amazing I saw that I had no better
I had nothing probably had something I
didn't see it I simply didn't see it
Bishop e3 watch must was much stronger
but okay Bishop f8 Bishop e3 maybe maybe
I can rocky I wouldn't have no time that
sets the second problem should eight
Bishop 83 rook see one still still quite
quite tricky come on and now we saw you
could even lose two moves and still win
yeah come on black resins Cham Cham so
okay let's let's see how black wins here
definitely there should be a window with
the hbu con cannot believe it here ok we
r minus five there according to the
engine which is no surprise but how do I
win now Queenie too and you can resign
him ok this is also winning chattox
takes be one check everyone check out 23
and I'm just a blind idiot yeah very
simple very simple head 20 seconds by
don't let see this stuff why don't i see
this i don't see
I don't know yeah I don't think
analyzing this is as much point you just
need a break i think for i'm starting to
trend about this game okay thanks for
watching bye